bonjour Nathalie Sautron de la société
action intérim donc j'ai intégré cette
société depuis 2004 sur un poste
sédentaire donc au recrutement et au fil
des années donc maintenant depuis 2011
je suis sur un poste commercial basé
bien sûr devant le BTP au départ puis
maintenant commercial sur toute la
partie tertiaire industrie manutention
cadre donc cette société donc action
intérim a été créée depuis maintenant 24
ans donc intérim moyen pense à s'appeler
c'est la première société de travail
temporaire implanté sur Lille donc
société on va dire créoliser et qui qui
a grossi au fil le des années donc avec
une agence et maintenant nous en avons
cinq agences physiques et dans cinq
agences nous avons d'autres agences et
au total aujourd'hui nous avons 8
agences de travail temporaires
donc actuellement nous recherchons un
chargé d'opération donc pour un poste en
CDI donc à pouvoir dès maintenant donc
un chargé d'opération avec des
connaissances une expérience dans le
bâtiment donc quelqu'un qui a un bon
sens relationnel
qui sachent bien sûr préparer une
réunion de chantier quelqu'un qui
communicatif avec le sens du terrain
également donc quelqu'un aussi qui sache
gérer administrativement un dossier de
chantier donc prendre un dossier pour la
préparation de chantier de A jusqu'à Z
la personne retenue sur ce poste
salaire d'environ de 2200 voire 2600 en
fonction bien sûr de son expérience tout
est en fonction du
profil de la personne qui sera retenue
sur le poste
bonjour je m'appelle Capron Damien j'ai
23 ans je suis actuellement à la
recherche d'un premier emploi de
préférence dans le multimédia je suis en
informatique à l'université de la
Réunion
j'habitue actuellement sur Saint-Denis
j'ai le permis de conduire je peux me
déplacer dans le nord et l'ouest de
l'île pour ce qui est de mes diplômes je
suis actuellement titulaire d'un Bac S
sciences de l'ingénieur d'un C2i qui est
une certification informatique et je
termine actuellement ma troisième année
de licence en informatique pour ce qui
est de mes expériences professionnelles
je j'ai pu acquérir quelques expériences
dans l'entreprise de mes parents
notamment en m'occupant du
parc informatique de l'entreprise
et grâce à l'université j'ai pu acquérir
quelques compétences en développement
web pour ce qui est de mes qualités je
pense pouvoir m'adapter rapidement
accepter les imprévus et y faire face et
je peux aussi grâce au programme de la
fac pouvoir parler anglais et suivre des
directives écrites en anglais j'aime les
sports collectifs le monde du multimédia
et je suis à l'écoute des autres
si vous avez besoin de moi n'hésitez pas
à me contacter
bonjour je m'appelle Cédric taracona
j'ai 24 ans je vis à Saint-Paul le
métier que j'aimerais faire c'est
développeur web alors ma formation j'ai
fait un bac STI génie électronique
ensuite un BTS système électronique et
ensuite une école d'ingénieur Epitech à
Bordeaux j'aimerais travailler dans
toute la Réunion c'est un Paul
Saint-Pierre Saint-Benoît ça me pose pas
de problème parce que j'ai le permis
j'ai une voiture et travailler en France
aussi me poserait pas de souci je suis
quelqu'un de très polyvalent je m'adapte
à beaucoup de situations
durant mon école d'ingénieur on nous
apprend beaucoup à travailler en équipe
je pense que c'est quelque chose de très
important dans une entreprise je suis
quelqu'un de très sportif j'ai fait du
football j'ai fait du volley j'ai fait
de la boxe je fais du football freestyle
j'ai fait beaucoup de sport j'ai
effectué un voyage linguistique en
Australie de 6 mois ce qui m'a permis de
développer mon niveau d'anglais j'ai un
niveau d'anglais très convenable pour
conclure je dirais que je suis quelqu'un
de très dynamique
je m'adapte très vite
j'espère que mon profil vous intéressera
merci à bientôt
bonjour je m'appelle Duchemin Olivier
j'ai 30 ans je suis titulaire du permis
B j'ai un véhicule je peux me déplacer
j'ai deux enfants et je recherche le
métier de coffreur brancheur je suis
titulaire du BAC action communication
commerciale que j'ai obtenu en candidat
libre
par la suite j'ai fait un BTS Management
des unité commerciale en alternance avec
l'entreprise du McDonald's dans le
commerce dans un premier temps j'ai eu
beaucoup de difficultés à trouver un
emploi j'ai dû me reconvertir assez vite
dans le bâtiment où j'ai trouvé vraiment
ma voix dans le cadre d'un recrutement
GTOI
j'ai suivi une formation théorique de
deux mois ma formation d'attente 2008
j'ai pu m'essayer à plusieurs métiers du
BTP comme coffreur blancheur ferrailleur
polyvalent endurant organisé je suis
également père de deux enfants en bas
âge ce qui me motive d'autant plus à me
déplacer sur toute l'île n'hésitez pas à
me contacter
contactez-nous sur votre page Facebook
le
www.facebook.com/974tv ou par téléphone
0262 92 37 60
9 7 4 CV votre émission au service de
l'emploi à la Réunion